love you be safe
oh
look at this look at that look how low
the water is this right here is like one
of my favorite fishing spots I usually
catch a ton of catfish and carp right
here welcome to another episode of the
outdoor boy YouTube channel I'm Luke and
this is my son Tom sup and we're going
to catch 200 pounds of fish is that
right Tom yes sir all right Tom let's
see if we can launch the boat I have no
idea whether we have enough water to
make the boat float off the trailer
I don't even know if I got the pontoons
wet
it's not even
true well I backed the car up all the
way until the tires were off the ramp
and into the mud and I still didn't have
the pontoons in the water Tommy I think
we need to come up with a plan B the
next day
just watch for cars
you know what you want
to
try going fish
ing
for all you wives out there who don't
understand why a man needs two fishing
boats here you go this one this one
we're gonna get launched
gotta make sure you don't forget to put
this back in
foreign
[Music]
when the water starts to get cold The
Bait fish move Downstream and collecting
the deep pools the catfish followed him
you want to find out where the catfish
are find The Bait fish
there we go that's a little school of
bait fish
two more
now you go there we go
we got a nice one look at that chunker
that's a gizzard check that's a big
gizzard shed it's beautiful
hey yo what the
bro
between the rain and the net I'm
constantly bailing this boat out
all right Tom we give it 15 minutes if
we don't catch a fish we move spots okay
okay so this is my 700 fishing boat with
a two thousand dollar fish finder and I
can see here this is the live scope I
could see what's going on directly under
the boat
we got some fish moving
oh
we got one right there don't we
get the teeth marks right there
I think you can tell Mom we don't need a
shower
you know the rain is really bad for
fishing the fish hate getting wet
hey Tom look at that
what do you think of that right there
ah dang it the hook point was buried in
the fish
so you're never gonna hook up well he's
he's pulling it look at that
time
really Limited
yep yep he is okay point the rod off to
your right point that out yeah direct
him away from the anchor line yeah you
got it
oh Tom that's a forehead
there you go
hey Tom high five
all right
yeah he's gut hooked a little bit I
gotta not even good week I'm really good
at sticking my hand inside the stomach
of flatheads and getting hooks back 21
pounds 21 pounds nice nice 21 pounder
look at me
there you go should I throw him back
yeah all right
all right
good job
not scagged
it's only the second time I've caught a
flathead on cut bait but let's go get it
you got back here yeah yeah
left ones going bonkers
all right Tom
that's a nice Channel kit that is a nice
channel catfish
ten and a half that's not bad just hold
them with your hands put your hands in
awesome congratulations Man why don't
you throw them back
I used to love going fishing with my dad
that was like
we're getting some hits but we're gonna
catch 200 pounds of catfish doing it
this way we need a better spot
yeah you you guys
yeah seeing some bait and deep water
here we're gonna try this
you're in the bite you gotta pull your
boot out Tom
that was a substantial fish
oh it's just popped off we'll throw it
back out there
Tom you hungry yeah
if you want you can eat a Shad I'll pass
you want it no
no you like sushi
let me wipe the poop off him real quick
[Music]
you want some
here open your mouth
yo we got all the food you need that's
actually pretty tasty
oh there's a as a foot it has a fish
aftertaste
like that after tasteful oh dog look at
that oh you tasted the shad and we got a
hit you need to taste more Shad you are
one with the catfish
oh
there he goes I can see him careful
doing that
Channel cat see how he's yellow like a
flat head
but look at his Tails yeah flat heads
don't have Fork Tails that's a channel
catfish that's a big Channel cat
put him in there
I think Tom's getting hungry and the
Shad just isn't cutting it I'm gonna
weigh up the fish here
thank you
all right there's one that's a nice one
so the big one's seven pounds
all right this one's three pounds that's
going to be 41 pounds three pounds yeah
not exactly a great day but uh we got
something
here we are well me and Tom have a lot
more fishing yet to do but we need to
pick up some bait
so uh we're gonna go here to H Mart
you want to get some yes okay grab a bag
oh that's a good one should we go we're
gonna get one
Chloe vera juice all right okay I'm
gonna ask this
okay we need yellow sugar all right we
need jello
Ah that's actually fish bait right there
[Music]
happens when you buy fish bait when
you're hungry
all right so I just made some new rice
and I put the old rice and some milk and
we're gonna make rice pudding with the
old rice
Tom what do you got there well you got
the Nerf version of a 50 cal BMG is it
cocked yeah
oh crap run run
people
we're gonna be on the boat for a bit
tomorrow so I'm gonna go ahead and make
lunch for tomorrow we're going pork ribs
all right Tom you want me to make you
some Bobby tofu yeah
I feel a disturbance in the forest
oh
yeah you gotta take some yeah I used to
eat Mobby tofu in Japan all the time
all right I gotta go get the boat ready
we're going fishing tomorrow it does
well I've made a mess in my wife's
kitchen but I got nine rods rigged up we
got the boat ready I think we're gonna
have some good fishing tomorrow I'll see
you guys then
day three of our challenge
ah
my life before
it's a nice boat but it's missing rod
holders all right it's time to get our
bait made up
yeah that's probably my favorite car
bait right there it's Panko bread crumbs
strawberry gelatin and sweet corn mixed
together and you're gonna see it it
works pretty good
wait
no we're there
[Music]
oh
that's Washington DC in the Washington
Monument right there
[Music]
all right guys we're at our spot and I'm
gonna use the Side Imaging sonar to try
to locate a pod of catfish and carp oh
look at that that's a big one right
there that's a big fish that's a big
fish that's a big fish oh there's some
right there on the bottom you can see
there they're not particularly huge
right now it looks like these fish are
congregated at the bottom of this hole
but as the tide goes out this could
change so we're gonna have to stay
flexible
I already saw a fish jump right there as
we're anchoring up all right guys so let
me show you my rig this is the whisker
Seeker catfish and carp series fishing
rod I designed this fishing rod and
whisker Seeker manufactures it and sells
it it's named after my fishing YouTube
channel the catfish and carp YouTube
channel I've got a little bit of Fake
Plastic corn on what's called a hair rig
and I've got this little dangly lead on
a slider this right here is like the
ultimate carp fishing rig so what I'm
gonna do is take a little ball of this
ponco Jello mix and I'm going to Mush it
around my lead
and I'm gonna stick my fake corn in the
bottom of that ball and cast it out
there it's gonna catch a lot of carb
when you're fishing with six rods that
little plastic corn pays big dividends
not having to bait your hook and check
your bait all the time really saves you
a lot of time it gets you in the water
faster over here on this Rod I've got
what's called a method lead it's a lead
weight specifically designed to hold
squishy Play-Doh like baits like this
it grips the bait better so you can cast
it harder
what do you got for lunch time Mama no
food
take it reach around there you go now
play him over here
oh Beauty Tom
there we go there we go we got him
oh look at that watch out Tom here he
comes
oh that is the stockiest stockiest carp
look at him he was a fighter man good
job
okay 16 pounds exactly
okay that thing is heavy
there you go Tom
congratulations here you want to put him
back yeah all right
that's about an average size one let's
see if we can't get some big ones all
right we got another one here yeah yeah
all right
it's not too bad eating pork ribs and
catching fish with my son on a beautiful
day
I'm get him get him get him get him
reel it really really
all right
oh there's yours all right get him yeah
don't worry about it don't worry about
it
bring them bring them over and see this
one separate
13 pounds I'm gonna let him go
sit fish in about 30 minutes yeah we go
what makes somebody
real and reel them is a good one he's
he's heading the right way so we got a
double nope yeah
it's not very big
when that fish shot off to the right you
could just see all these Torpedoes right
under the surface of the water just
dozens of carp running for it
don't worry Tommy don't worry don't
worry I got it I got it now if you get
tired let me know I'll help you out
[Music]
well that's it put it down in Denver
your net needs to be deeper yeah yo you
got it Tom I'm so happy yeah he is heavy
oh
nice
16 pounds oh yeah
so 150. oh he made a mess of our rods
[Music]
went down
yeah it's barely been in there yeah
there you go he's pretty
you think that's heavier
he is 12 pounds 12 pounds
you know what we are I don't know Tommy
it's been like two minutes without a
fish you know this spot's been doing
pretty good but it's starting to cool
off and I think I'd like to Anchor a
little further Upstream but uh Tommy has
a little bit of a need we need to take
care of real up Tommy we'll go find a
bathroom
we got to pull up this net full of all
the little carp weigh them up and see
what we got in there
yeah five fish in there including our
little Prussian car
32 pounds check it out this is the
Prussian carp this is a full-sized one
you notice he doesn't have any barbels
and he's kind of silver colored a little
bit more round Bodied
now these are common carp you see they
got the whiskers on the side of their
mouth they're kind of a gold color a
little bit longer
foreign
[Music]
potty break and we're ready to go catch
some more fish
I think we're gonna go ahead and anchor
just a bit Upstream from where we were
before
that took about three minutes
all right
there you go
yeah
no it's it's
all right that's a decent size 12 pounds
nice chunky one one
they're like chocolate Jammy Dodgers
yeah I take it down really reel it
still on I got off and that's all right
we'll
run landed one but it's gotten real
quiet so I think we need to move spots
okay there's a few right there so we
just passed a couple fish over here one
there one there let's give this a shot
here Tom not sure this spot's gonna be
awesome but I'm pretty sure we're gonna
pull something out of here let's give it
15 more minutes and see what happens
you got him what did you do with my fish
yes
hey you want to reel this one in yeah
cool don't lose this one
oh stocky boy look at this one he's got
like a horn growing out of the side of
his face
look at that is that crazy he is 12
pounds beautiful
carp
it's beautiful
all right
eight pounds eight pounds nice okay you
throw them back yeah there you go little
friend it's gotten kind of quiet so
we're gonna pick up move spots
oh we don't have a lot of
hitting it pretty quick
oh
that is a no joke fish right there
yeah he is the Beast here we go dog get
him get him you got him get up get that
net off
fish behind you fish behind it go get
him behind him go get him
oh
25 pounds
carp you better put him back
oh that is a big fish Dom that's not 16
pounds
23 pounds 23 high five Bud look how fat
this one is
sure sure put your hands out again
good job Tom all right if you can put
them in the water
hey buddy
slide me high five
slimy high fives look there's a
fireworks show over there
foreign
that is a blue catfish we have now
caught all three species of catfish
Flathead Channel and blue
catfish love the corn and panko six
pounds here we go
oh guys it's getting so late we don't
have any flashlights I don't know if we
made our challenge or not I know we're
close to 200 pounds but I'm not sure but
we're gonna have to go home and review
the footage to know exactly what
happened
[Music]
foreign
yes awesome well let's get home and look
at the footage and figure out whether or
not we we made our challenge
what do you think Tom how much fish do
you think we caught between 300 and 250.
let me show you we did it we did it
what do you think I'm proud yeah you
should be listen I hope you guys enjoyed
watching this as much as we enjoyed
doing it if you guys want to see more
fishing videos from the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel make sure to check out
our fishing video playlist and don't
forget to click subscribe to the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel because we put out
videos every Saturday and morning click
subscribe
[Music]
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button and you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]